today's new member of the day is kim
nova pne's kim thank you i really can't
thank you enough but at least for today
i'll just thank you once for being a
supporter of the david pakman show kim
has signed up at WWN pakman.com she's
doing the right thing she can afford it
and she's saying i'm going to support
the david pakman show because not
everybody can I also want to say thanks
to William koukin doll who has been a
member for almost five years William and
Kim two very very special people
among the many David Pakman show
supporters join them on our website
www.jfn.co.jp/toho if you want just like
a massive monumental discount off of
your membership saturday is my 35th
birthday and we are going to be having a
35 themed membership discount it's gonna
be huge
okay if it's even remotely interesting
get on our newsletter at david
pakman.com alright let's get into hey
tree at mail for the week if you've not
been introduced it's a hatred mail
here's a quick summary to get you set up
for it because the government that is
supposedly totally annette is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
hatred mail written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom alright so we're continuing to
debut new musical backing tracks for
hatred mail we've had just one backing
track for years and we've introduced a
couple of new ones after obtaining the
rights to some of these tracks it was a
huge huge negotiation whereby we just
paid 25 bucks per track on a music
licensing site very very quick and easy
but it's ramping up the entire tone and
tenor of hatred mail let's take a listen
to this week's I wish I didn't have to
believe in such things but building
seven shouldn't have fallen the Pentagon
violated aerodynamic laws speaking of
ground effects not saying that the
Illuminati is coming to get us but the
official story is offs sopra if a
building was damaged so much that it
were to fall it would fall to the
direction of the damage good man what
are the odds of that right yeah
all of a sudden Pat everybody is
well-versed in a building engineering
and physics and can tell us exactly how
everything should happen under
circumstances to which they've never
been exposed this is what I call a
basement physicist this hey treat male
is unlike the others I didn't see the
word soy boy or beta or coq or NPC is
this is different I like it a little bit
more yeah it's merely conspiratorial it
doesn't include any of the normal add
homonyms that we've come to know and not
really love but at least except
acquiesce to would be maybe the best way
to say it remember that you can use the
coupon code hate reott 40 when you sign
up for a membership at WWE at medCom you
can choose any of the memberships there
apply the coupon code hey tree at 40 and
you will save 40% and 1,100 hatreds cry
every time that that coupon code is used
so something to think about